we moved back in May of the next year so
there's about you know seven eight
months where it's just this whole new
dynamic because my mom took care of
everyone my whole life she was the
person you called if you had any
difficulty you know you have to borrow
money you hit a mom you know don't worry
but dad's there but he's more of a
mascot you know he's the mask that
sounds shitty to say but like on the
team that is my parents my mom's George
Steinbrenner you know what I mean she
runs the operation yeah and dad he's
there to raise morale you know if you're
having a party yeah exactly yes my dad's
the Philly fanatic and my mom is trying
to build a [__] franchise you know
she wants to hang some she wants to hang
some pennies from the rap yes
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]